- [Instructor] Although they came
from very different backgrounds,
Arthur Brooks and Grace
Hopper were an early pioneer
in computer programming.
All right, so who is an early pioneer?
Well, they're talking
about two different people
being an early pioneer.
You have Arthur Brooks and Grace Hopper.
So you have two people.
You have two people right over here.
And two people can't just
be one early pioneer,
as the underlined portion implies.
It says an early pioneer.
Well, we have two people
so they're both going to be pioneers.
So they are both early pioneers,
so I would wanna replace
that with early, early,
actually let me do it this way.
I wanna replace this with early pioneers
in computer programming
'cause we're talking
about two people being
pioneers, not just one.
And that is this choice right over here.
If you look at these other two choices,
these would be incorrect because
these are still referring
to only one person, a
pioneer, a very early pioneer.
We don't have just one pioneer,
we have two pioneers
so that's why we wanna go with pioneers.